اقف هنا على الجسر الرئيسي في بلده
متروفيتسا الشماليه كوسوفو الذي يمر فوق
نهر البار ويفصل البلده الى جزئين جزءا
جنوبي تقتله اغلبيه البانيه مسلمه نسمع
المواطنين الان يؤدون صلاه الجمعه في هذا
المسجد الذي نراه امامنا وعلى الجانب
الاخر في الجزء الشمالي على بعد عشرات
الامتار فقط نرى الجزء الذي تقطنه اغلبيه
سلبيه يستعد للناس لاحيائي ليله عيد
الميلاد حسب تقويم الارثوذكسي بعد ساعه
قليله من الان هذا المشهد يلخص حقيقه
النزاعات والتوترات العراقيه والدينيه في
هذه المنطقه من كتب التوترات التي شهدناها
ميدانيا خلال الاسابيع الماضيه من خلال
الحواجز التي نصبها ناشطون السر باحتجاجا
على بعض القرارات التي اتخذتها حكومه قبل
ان تفكك قوات قوات حفظ السلام التي حلف
شمال الاطلسي اخر هذه الحواجز خلال
الساعات الماضيه استعدادا لوصول المبعوثين
الاوروبي والامريكي الى المنطقه الاسبوع
المقبل لاجراء حوارات سياسيه بغيه ايجاد
ايطالي حلل ينهي امكانيه التجدد مثل هذه
التوترات في المستقبل محمد المدهون
الجزيره من بلده متروفيتسا شماليه كوسوفو